(hinge creaks)
- Hi, I'm Adriane Kruer.
I'm a clinical psychologist
in Los Angeles.
I've been working with kids and
families for about 10 years.
I am a licensed psychologist working
with children ages three to 18.
I started working with children
when I did a master's in art therapy.
I really love working with families
to help them understand their kids better,
communicate better,
and get along better with
their friends and family.
So some of the signs of
depression in children
might be not wanting to do things
that they normally like to do,
like they don't wanna go to
their normal soccer practice,
they might not want to go to a sleepover
and they normally would really like that.
Another thing that kids might show
when they're feeling depressed
is some bodily symptoms.
They might have headaches more often,
maybe more stomachaches.
They might go to the
nurse's office more often.
They might also have trouble getting along
with other kids at school
or with their siblings.
You might hear about
this at a school meeting.
Kids might also be a
little more irritable.
Maybe they have more outbursts.
You might notice that
they're a little more angry
than they normally would be.
That would definitely be a sign
that they're having some
sort of sadness going on.
When talking with your
kids about their feelings,
it is really important to let them know
that you are safe to talk to,
that you can be there for them.
Kids when they're feeling
sad might not understand
that they feel depressed.
They may not know what's
really going on for them.
So it's really important as adults
that we provide a really
safe space for them to talk.
We might want to give
them a lot of reassurance
and provide them some
encouragement to open up.
If you do have concerns
that your child is in danger
or they may have thoughts
of hurting themselves or someone else,
it is important to reach
out for help right away.
Don't wait.
So you can call your local
emergency services, 911,
or the suicide hotline.
They do have a youth division.
Paying attention to
feelings is really important
to understand how we are
getting along in the world
with ourselves and with other people.
Reaching out to a professional
can be a great way
to just start the conversation.
Kids can make a lot of
progress in therapy.
They can really start to understand
who they are as people, even
when they're very little,
so it's nice for them to have a space
where they can get to know themselves,
start to understand how
they wanna be in the world.
(bright music)